et ça ressort depuis des années déjà
Matthieu en réalité et je vous rappelle
je trouve ça scandaleux et ça juste
parce que il n'est plus là pour se
défendre et parce qu'en plus la loi ne
me permet pas de pouvoir faire des
procédures en diffamation et donc tout
le monde peut implément dire raconter
calomnier colporter et c'est exactement
ce qui se passe il est mon père est
associé
la pédophilie parce que c'est donc ça
revient à le mettre dans le même stage
même sac le mars dutrousse qui est juste
encore une fois ce qu'on a vu je vous
invite à regarder la définition du mot
pédophilie et on est impuissant voilà
donc en fait je voudrais c'est que
j'espère qu'on est dans une société qui
qui a un petit peu plus de de sens moral
civile et de savoir-vivre parce que
encore une fois il est plus là pour se
défendre je sais qui était mon père et
c'est c'est en fait d'avoir encore ces
adjectifs associés à son nom alors vous
avez raison qu'on n'est pas dans une
société très nuancée aujourd'hui ni
d'ailleurs à la télévision et je m'en
excuse c'est vrai que mais juste deux
dernières questions ce magazine dont on
parle qu'il avait créé et on disait
qu'il prenait lui-même les mannequins en
photo
voilà c'était il prenait des mannequins
très jeune en photo il est il aimait
bien les jolies filles jeunes on va dire
il aimait bien les jolies filles il se
trouve que il y avait des jeunes des
moins jeunes mais
beaucoup de meufs de 35 ans
voilà mais peut-être même un peu plus
mais on ne parle en aucun cas d'enfants
d'accord mais c'est bien c'est très bien
14 ans c'est très bien de vous entendre
parce que j'entends beaucoup de gens qui
sont parfois aussi un peu complotistes
et qui disent n'importe quoi votre avis
m'intéresse beaucoup et j'ai une
dernière question je vais pas vous
déranger mais c'est de vous que ça doit
sortir il y a eu cette soi-disant
enquête de la police belge qui avait
enquêté sur votre sœur qui serait née
d'une femme qui avait 14 ans
alors 15 ans 15 ans effectivement
d'accord 15 ans quand elle a accouché
donc elle avait 14 ans
et je veux pas le faire par téléphone
parce que ça peut pas se faire en une
histoire et compliquée
je peux vous dire ce que c'est voilà je
ne suis pas exprimé parce que j'ai parlé
à la maman d'accord et j'ai compris
qu'en réalité julie était une femme
fragile et c'était délicat pour moi de
rentrer en interaction de cette histoire
d'accord mais mais on peut en gros dire
que c'est un manque de vigilance et
est-ce que je peux ce que je peux vous
assurer c'est que mon père ne
connaissait pas l'âge de sa maman quand
il l'a rencontré qui avait été formé
qu'elle parlait quatre langues qu'il
avait tout lieu de croire
qu'elle était beaucoup plus vieille que
ce qu'elle était en réalité et je vous
crois et ça m'ennuie de vous poser que
des questions là-dessus parce qu'il y a
tellement de choses que j'aime chez
votre père mais c'était très très
important pour moi aussi que dans ton
nouveau
votre avis à vous parce que c'est votre
père et vous avez donné une petite vous
allez tout comprendre un jour elle lui a
donné son âge elle lui dit mais tu crois
que j'ai quel âge et quand elle lui a
dit j'ai 15 ans elle me c'est elle qui
me raconte il est devenu blême il l'a
regardé il lui a dit il était folle et
qui finissent en tôle ouais elle est
flamande donc la tôle elle savait pas ce
que ça voulait dire bien c'est l'argot
français et quand elle me raconte ça ça
s'invente pas voilà donc
j'entends j'ai mes deux dernières
questions et après je vous promets que
si vous voulez venir en plateau on fera
que danser et tout parce que je peux pas
dire parce que votre père il est il est
parce que votre père c'est une icône
il les rend heureux et exactement et ben
moi le premier je là ça je l'ai pas
inventé qu'est-ce que je voulais vous
dire deux questions est-ce que votre
sœur vous la voyez ou jamais
bon et j'ai une dernière question j'ai
une dernière question ok moyennement
agréable et après je vous jure vous
venez en plateau on déjeune ensemble on
est les meilleurs amis il y a Dany qui a
dit dans un documentaire sur Arte quand
je l'ai regardé c'était quelqu'un de
formidable mais très colérique elle dit
un jour je l'ai vu sortir de l'Olympia
des coulisses de l'Olympia il avait une
secrétaire qui lui tenait son verre
d'eau une un miroir le miroir était trop
bas il l'a pris il lui a éclaté sur la
tête c'était un personnage particulier
quand même
j'étais pas là après il était colérique
oui parce que et en fait il avait trois
emplois du temps dans la même journée il
était resta qui était andersaire et il
était artiste et chacun de ces rôles
avaient des plannings bien chargés et
donc bien sûr que ça rend insupportable
le manque d'attention de rigueur et puis
l'exigence dans laquelle il était il l'a
voulu de la part de tout son entourage
donc ça pouvait l'excéder par moment
mais j'ai le début de taper qui que ce
soit j'habite à miroir sur la tête j'ai
une question de Rome et déjà je voulais
vous remercier parce que je trouve ça
très beau la manière dont vous défendre
de votre père et je trouve ça très très
bien et
des défauts mais bien sûr
mais là on en fait un monstre de
régulièrement mais c'est pour ça que je
voulais vous entendre parce que c'est
pas un monstre pour moi du tout je peux
vous promettre que c'est c'est là où
vous avez raison et puis je pense que
quand on a ce niveau d'exigence et qu'on
est premier pour rester premier signe
anxiété tous les jours Laurent a une
question Claude salut une question à te
poser qui arrive rien à voir depuis des
années j'ai envie de voir ton avis sur
le sujet que les droits de comme
d'habitude ont été cédés un milliardaire
français est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas
vrai c'est une partie des droits c'est
un catalogue éditorial éditorial qui a
été cédé un consenseur d'investisseurs
français qui est déjà très bien que la
plupart des copyright aux États-Unis et
donc c'est géré par Emmanuel de burten
les chefs Duval c'est une société qui
s'appelle because d'accord c'est des
anciens de chez Virgin musique et j'ai
très bien géré et j'en suis voilà bon
mauvais très bien